someone who has seen insane growth is
Sam suck oh God yeah what do you think
about Sam
suck I'm I am this is I'm so fascinated
how certain people just pop off on
social media like I'm trying to
understand the what has the formula been
like I didn't I didn't know of him
before until it's basically kind of you
see the memes first you're like why is
there a meme about this guy and then you
go onto the Instagram you go on to the
YouTube and you just see like the the
following and the consistently high
views and you're like oh what what he
what's he doing then and you watch it
and it's just like pretty normal there's
no fancy edits or anything cinematic
it's just I think the reason why it's
worked so well is because he's just
gotten almost in the opposite direction
in in in instead of trying too hard with
like the showing off and the the musics
the edits he's just like this is just is
edits it's just
it's
like like after that first thing it's
just as far as I know it's just a camera
on a tripod and he's just doing his
thing and sharing his thoughts which is
very simple
but it kind after watching it makes
sense why it works he has some in a lot
of insightful things to say I think uh I
heard this term the other day growth
hacking
authenticity um and I think that
everybody now is
so skeptical of someone that's
contriving uh a a version of themselves
if you see someone that looks like
they're trying too hard or they're
putting on a a particular it's just
there's discomfort and ick and oh I
don't like that and I
think Sam's lack of fancy car or fancy
edit or fancy thumbnails or like any of
that is just a signal of reliability I
think that's what people I think it's
very relatable if you think about how
many men are in a similar situation to
him I remember when I when I started the
YouTube channel like everything was
really basic I was in you know not a
very it was a terrorist house in
Newcastle I was doing my meal prep video
in a pretty shabby kitchen my pots and
pans were all completely [__] up like
there was no lubrication on it it was
just sticking to everything and I was
just doing my meal prep shopping at
little or Aldi and just it to work with
me and people love that cuz so many
people could relate to it and I remember
the moment I kind of moved away from
that staying in more fancier places when
I upgraded to my apartment in London and
I left London and came to Dubai it was
my audience was divided there was half
of them who were like really inspired
and they were like wow like look what
he's done I want to do this as well and
then there's the other half who were
just like I I can't really relate to you
anymore like I can't relate to your life
y I mean make make no mistake man if I
was to guess
the revenue that Sam is making per month
forget his hostile uh sponsorship and
forget the other stuff just from
AdSense I reckon it's at least a quarter
of a m yeah he's banging out a video
nearly every day daily videos of half a
m yes probably qu of a mill a month
there is always Trends in the industry
like something comes along from nowhere
and is very
popular but there's very few things that
remain that popular over a long period
of time like will it get to a point
where his style of
videos are not going to do it for people
like it gets to a point where it's oh
it's boring now like let me find
something what's the next hot trending
thing yeah well there's definitely for
every Trend there is a counterculture
Trend so I said this before if you want
to predict the future look at the trend
that exists now for which there hasn't
yet been the exact opposite so for every
um let's say like Mike thir well edited
Fitness Vlog with like cool [__]
cinematic lighting and a guy with a
Gimbal and stuff there's a Sam suck
which is kind of the same thing but
delivered in in a very different sort of
a way um summer 2020 everyone's lock
down no one can go out summer 2021 Megan
the stallion just hot girl summer dress
yourself up go out you know like have
casual sex like be doled and Glam summer
2022 is feral girl
which is be a sloth don't shave don't
wash you don't need to be bothered even
leaving the house just eat beans in your
pajamas so like you have culture or
Trend and then counterculture or counter
Trend and I think that Sam largely is
not necessarily probably worst example
to use you I don't know who he's quite
the antithesis of but he's definitely
counter to much of the fitness industry
that is contrived that's like um you
know kind of like the equivalent of the
pop Idol boy band that was like pieced
together like you're the cool one and
you're the whatever one it doesn't feel
like that it's just some bloke going
about his day
but and I I said this on an episode with
Zach and people got mad about it I still
think it's the truth if Sam wasn't Elite
level jacked people wouldn't follow him
I think that what works about Sam if Sam
was some skinny skinny fat guy that
wasn't in good condition wasn't lifting
heavy didn't have really great insight
about Fitness he's just some bloke going
to the gym that's a lot of peopley so
that's all that's everyone's YouTube
that's every person's YouTube channel I
think that Sam is a likable relatable
guy who happens to be [__] massive
and it's like oh like he's me but better
yeah he's so much of what we have is
relatable and is the
same and on top of that he's you know
bodybuilder huge was like I look at seum
as well like seum has this huge huge
like he is the biggest name in
bodybuilding now and I try and think
okay so why why is that the case
obviously he he looks amazing but he's
such a nice humble guy as well that I
can't imagine why anyone would ever have
a problem with him so you combine that
super jacked amazing physique with just
being a nice humble guy and it does
without a doubt get harder to remain
humble when you have that many people
who are idolizing you and you have like
over 21 million people following you to
not let that get to your head well
there's two two ways that it can get to
your head the first one being your ego
is being inflated by everyone thinking
that you're great the second one is you
becoming defensive and bitter about all
of the people criticizing you yeah so
you it works in two different ways I'm
going to become more harsh and and more
uh quick to attack because people have
done it to me in the the past and all of
these people are telling me that I'm
great and I've got five championships
how the [__] am I not like the best in
the world and everyone should listen to
me like hard it's hard to especially if
you're combining it with like if you're
taking you know some steroids as well
like that can also mess up with your
mentality in the way that you're
thinking yeah yeah I
wonder you know that I was watching uh a
couple of videos from the trend twins as
well and uh they're like I find them
like a pretty interesting interesting
pair like they're an interesting pair of
dudes
but uh Sam is just a [__] Phenom at
the moment what's his face cam Haynes
brought him up to Rogan yesterday on uh
on his show have you heard of this Sam
suck kid it's like there you go Derek
from more plates more dates did it as
well in a little way I think he you know
he purposefully didn't make his uh yeah
like he he could have definitely leveled
up with the production yep but is that
no no people just wanted that like
relatability like high level
Insight sprinkling of autism like that's
that's what they wanted from there
sometimes I try not to get too heavily
influenced you know I've had Iman gadzi
on the show and the production quality
on his videos is absolutely like insane
like best of the best and then I'm
thinking [__] maybe I need to get to
like that level of production but I I
don't I don't need to I just just focus
on what it is that you're going to say
thing cuz if you go too hard with the
production it it gets a bit distracting
and maybe again it becomes unrelatable
this episode is brought to you by
element element is a tasty electrolyte
drink mix with everything that you need
and nothing that you don't it's a
healthy alternative to sugary
electrolyte drinks it's got a science
packed electrolyte ratio of sodium
potassium and magnesium you might ask
what do I want with an electrolyte drink
well it'll regulate your appetite it'll
curb Cravings it'll help improve your
brain function best of all it tastes
phenomenal first thing in the morning
this orange element salt in water is
outstanding your adenosine system that
caffeine acts on isn't even active for
the first 90 minutes of the day so it's
it's pointless having a morning coffee
your adrenal system which is what salt
acts on is active so this will make you
feel more alert more awake and improve
your hydration best of all they've got a
no BS no questions asked refund policy
so you can buy it and if you do not like
it for any reason they will give you
your money back that's how confident
they are that you'll love it head to
drink LM nt.com slod wisdom to get a
free sample pack of all eight flavors
with your first box that's drink LM
nt.com
slod wisdom thank you very much for
tuning in if if you enjoyed that clip
then press here for the full episode in
all its Glory